your mind here's the debate
you're upset they're saying we believe
[Music]
i thought
it's pretty loud
it is
all right folks today episode number 145
with
former presidential candidate dr joe
jorgensen who got i want to say this
correctly 1.8 million votes 1.2 percent
and she a lot of people who are on here
with us they voted for her you supported
her and at the end we're gonna do some
calls for people to be able to call in
and find out what this whole libertarian
thing is that everyone's talking a lot
of crypto people nowadays call
themselves libertarian we're gonna have
the presidential candidate break that
down for us dr joe jorgensen thank you
so much for being a guest today glad to
be here thank you it's great to have you
on so uh for the audience who doesn't
know what it is to be a libertarian what
is a libertarian to you
somebody who believes that we each have
the right to make our own choices
and that society works much better if we
can each interact voluntarily
rather than having the government be in
charge of us
okay so you would say so make our own
choices so so far that doesn't seem very
controversial everybody would say i want
to be able to make my own choices for
myself now you're saying that the both
the democrats and the republicans
want to make choices for you oh
absolutely just look at the recent
covid and schools when it just broke my
heart how mothers were going before
school boards begging
please teach my child in person
please
don't make them wear a mask they're
getting behind socially they're getting
behind educationally and
there was no choice because it was a
monopolistic system so let's just say
during covet we had joe jorgensen as our
president how different would things
have been
oh like night and day let's let's hear
it i'm curious uh no mask requirements
of course no business shutdowns and what
a lot of people don't realize they say
well it was so good though that we shut
down the economy so that people didn't
get sick but you have to look at
politicians being politicians of course
they allowed the big box stores to be
open they let the big guys be open it's
the small mom and pop stores that they
shut down so you know people think well
we need politicians we need government
to help the little guy but it's actually
government that's hurting the little guy
and
what's very distressing uh hearing the
message from the left i would love to
explain to everybody on the left who
says corp you know big corporations are
bad we need to cut them down to size
well
big corporations are big because of
government
it's it's because government is giving
them special privileges and powers and
money can you can you go even a little
bit deeper than us so let's stay there
okay covet it is kobe 20 20. so
uh wouldn't anthony fauci be there under
a pres under your presidency would we
have a surgeon general
that would come out or somebody from the
cdc or somebody from the nih that would
come out and say well here's what's
going on with kovit here's what we got
to look at with this here's we got to
get the vaccine it's going to take us 9
to 18 months how different would you
have been that urgent would you have
shut down travel restrictions coming in
from china would you have restricted
people coming in from europe for the
period that we had what were some of the
decisions you would have made no i would
not have restricted people and there
would be no anthony fauci
giving edicts
it's one thing to have
a medical
unit as an advisory committee
it's another though to allow them to be
making decisions for instance the cdc
was basically making decisions
on rent on whether or not you could
affect attendance that's such an
overreach of what it was intended
okay but go a little deeper for me if
there wouldn't be an anthony fauci who's
given us updates and what are we
learning so you're a medical doctor your
medical doctor so so how about if i
can't afford medical because i don't
have a medical doctor who's telling me
what to do with covet oh we could spend
two hours just on medicine so if i could
divert there a lot of people say you
know capitalism isn't working so we need
to have uh you know
one size fits all we need to have
socialized medicine
well we don't
have capitalism in medicine what we've
got is we do have so many rules and
regulations that uh
that we're not getting the competition
needed and the biggest example would be
insurance
a lot of people say well insurance is
too high well that's because it's not
insurance
what if your car insurance paid for
oil changes getting your car washed and
putting gas in your car
you wouldn't go around looking for the
cheapest gas station because what do you
care
uh insurance companies going to pay for
it anyway
and then
the next year your
premiums are going to go up because
the insurance companies are going to
have to raise prices because you weren't
looking for the cheapest option right
now there's absolutely no incentive to
look for the cheapest option in fact i
gave birth to both my daughters in a
birthing center it was basically a
three-bedroom house
uh that had a kitchen you even had to
bring your own food
excuse me and this was in the 1980s
and i think it was like 900 and that and
you know you get the doctor and i
remember telling a friend of mine like
wow you know the birthing center and
only 900
and she said oh but i want to go to the
new women's center
uh and and there just been this big
story about how they had redone it and
they had six hundred dollar
uh bed spreads
and i don't remember how many thousands
of dollars it cost but no skin off of
their nose
so and and now i realize that's an
extreme that's a higher um that's at the
higher end
but even just going into the doctor for
a checkup or going in because you have
an ear infection
uh that should that that would be a lot
cheaper than taking your car and if we
can take our car in for a 300
uh
repair then why can't we go to the
doctor and get you know 90 dollar
checkup but but
dr joe let's go back to it so it's kovid
so there's no one that's going to give
me updates on what's going on with kobit
we're not shutting down fine i like that
we're not
closing travel coming in from china so
we'll get do you mind if i interrupt
please and
you said nobody is giving updates
uh the free market would definitely be
giving updates i mean we've got
companies now who are giving us updates
about about other things out there so
why wouldn't some why wouldn't there be
some let's say
mcdonald's of healthcare who was saying
give putting advertisements on tv saying
okay this is what the latest research is
showing you need to come to our clinic
for
whatever to get tested whatever so
no we get a lot of
information in the free market in fact
look at all the information we get off
the internet if i may yeah oh please
yeah so your president
we know we know it's a pandemic and it's
coming fast and heavy what would your
administration response be to a populist
that is scared to death of this word
pandemic and they're hearing it coming
what would we have heard from your
administration
in terms of a national response because
this isn't just bad flu season this is a
pandemic well okay but let's back up
part of the reason there was so much
fear was because the government put the
fear in people if you look at college
age kids high school kids the death rate
for this was actually lower than the flu
for younger people even lower than that
you don't get up to the death rate of
the flu until you get much older so
again would we be doing this for the flu
would we be shutting everything down
would we be calling it a pandemic like
that that's what i was getting back to
is asking you to just kind of elaborate
for us and pat's question about so you
would have been as our president coming
to the microphone saying hang on a
second we're using the word pandemic but
you would have then said well wait wait
but but but who put the word pandemic
out there to begin with
it was the president it was the
government so i'd be coming out there
saying as you've seen in the news we've
got this new uh
we've got this new disease going around
we've got this new virus
and i would act as a leader
not as a king i would act as a leader
telling people you know
go to your medical professional go to
your doctor go to now of course
under a libertarian
administration
if we had fixed health care to the point
to where it wasn't a monopolistic system
because that gets back to you know we
talk about high cost
doctors are a government-run monopoly
the government grants
how you know indirectly grants how many
people can get nds and how many people
can practice i mean if they did that for
plumbers and car mechanics
that would be sky high too so
if we had different people out there
providing services an increase in nurse
practitioners and so on it would be much
cheaper and we could easily say go to
your health care provider so i think
i i relate to some of the uh you know
elements of libertarian i do i fully
relate to it i get it
but for me it feels like to do what you
want to do
if you were president 2020 it would be a
mess
and here's oh and it's not a message and
it
it was totally a mess but let me explain
to you why i think it would be even a
bigger mess
because i think to do
what you want to do or even inject that
spirit
don't you think it makes more sense to
start from congress
senate
governor and work your way up to have
other people that are infrastructure
that are
like if i would ask you right now how
many of our congressmen are libertarians
registered libertarians how many would
there be oh none how many senators do we
have that are registered
you're not gonna you don't have you
don't have poll so okay let's just say
you're president you wouldn't get
nothing done in today's system though
but in today's system let's just say if
you were to become president
in today's system
who's going to back you up from the left
to the right
they have a monopoly today except if i
were president then there would also be
incoming senators and congress people
because it's not going to be one person
getting elected out of everybody it's
going to be a movement there are going
to be other people you really think that
somebody's going to elect a third-party
president and only the president is
going to be liberated i think i think no
i don't think that i think uh you know i
think the movement is going to need help
from different places i do believe that
but you also need backing now don't get
me wrong the first
the best third party candidate of all
time is who abraham lincoln he's the
first republican right he was third
party came out boom you can tell the
teddy roosevelt story right on what he
did you can go look at ross parole
people will throw george wallace in
there ron paul and there's a lot of
names that they'll throw in the
best third party candidates right but
wouldn't it make sense to
go
and get others internally
converted rather than going straight to
the top because if you can pull up some
of the numbers so some will say the
following some will say
uh uh president biden is president today
because of you
meaning and they would be wrong but go
ahead but i would show you the numbers
some would say that you're the reason
why president biden is president
pull up the numbers i just texted you
pull up the numbers i just texted you i
don't know if you have that or not if
you can put it on this well like for
instance
i did beat the spread in several states
for instance pennsylvania i did beat the
spread but what you would have to say is
something like 80 85 percent of the
people who voted for me all would have
gone to trump and that's not the way it
would have gone we tend to get votes
from both sides so it may be if every
single vote i got went to one person but
that's not the way it works well more
more libertarians would probably align
themselves
with a uh trump than they would with a
body that's not what the research shows
we draw equally from democrats and
republicans do you think so that that's
what the research shows absolutely so
you know
well yeah well i mean describe the
democrat that comes across let her
finish let me i want to actually hear
what she's going to do well actually i
was
what i was doing was i was basically
going to be answering your question
uh
look at cannabis
uh reform that's libertarian and that's
on the left look at marriage equality
where gays are allowed to get married
that's libertarian and that's on the
left
um abortion although i tend to not you
know that that's an issue that i stay
away from and there
ron paul
made a libertarian argument for being
pro-life so you know i
that that's a very inflammatory so but
but that would be where um democrats and
the libertarian party uh would agree on
immigration i mean you go right down the
line there are many people who come over
from the left and i've talked with many
of them in fact i met somebody at
bitcoin yesterday
who very very interesting story he was
on the left
and then he went to a diversity class
and the professor at
a college and the
he was the only
male in the class
and he's or maybe a white male but the
professor said if you are a white male
there is a hundred percent chance that
you're going to rape somebody and he was
just appalled so he immediately became a
conservative
but then he didn't like some of those
ideas and then he found out about the
libertarian party he said okay that's me
so
go ahead tom
now that's i was going to ask is to
describe the typical dem that would come
across and the typical republican would
come across who were those voters
because we've learned about
that identity politics that you see
through the media doesn't really define
anybody but then we discover
with a lot of democratic
demographic acuity like what happened to
terry mcauliffe when the mothers of
children in virginia were so incensed on
the level of control over the education
of their kids and we can see that it was
all races but this the common stripe was
women with children under 8th grade
really flipped out and turned on him and
so that's what i was looking for is
groups like that that you can describe
it's like young people that are at
public schools but that came from public
education with this and this i didn't
know if there was like
typical you know
kind of an archetype for these voters
you talked about issues but i was kind
of curious about the people groups and
typicalities such as
moms of kids under 8th grade of all
races and economic backgrounds attacked
terry mcauliffe and he was not governor
of virginia
right and i was so glad to see him leave
now
unfortunately you mentioned kids in
public schools and if we extend that to
college unfortunately most of them are
going to the left and
we gotta we got to put a stop to that
problem in fact i
am part of the founding of an
organization of libertarian educators
to trying to get together to see okay
how can we stop this how can we get in
there and because
you know something like 92 96
of professors lean to the left and we've
got to get in there and show them and
opposing
a more sane
uh alternative so so if you again like
the point i was trying to make that the
the 1.8 million votes you got the 1.2
percent the count the states that you
got it you know uh georgia 14 152 votes
in georgia you had 61 000 792 in that
state that's 16 electoral that would
have gone the other way arizona had 49
182 wisconsin at 38 000 415 that's 10
electoral electoral votes that would
ended up being a tie 269 269 if you can
john if you can show that on the screen
and zoom it in a little bit more so
people can see it so just to kind of
give some context here as well this the
14 000 votes is what biden beat trump
with in that state and then obviously
you have the gap which is you in the
middle there uh on those votes as well
so just with these four states you you
could make i mean i know that people do
make the argument zoom in a little bit
people those would have pushed you over
would have pushed one way or the other
uh and then possibly pushed for for
trump on that end as well yeah well as i
said many people from the left also vote
libertarian and
in the past historically it's about 50
50. although most of our votes
come from independents or people who
have never voted before so if somebody's
never voted before and and many people
came up to me when i was on the campaign
trail saying
it wasn't worth it for me to vote for
before i'm 30 years old 40 years old
whatever because everybody out there is
just the typical politicians but typical
politician but you're different
and so
i don't think they would have voted for
trump okay fine so again some argument
is ralph nader is the reason why bush
won
you know ross pro is why clinton won and
you're why trump won some people may say
that but i want to go on issues let's
just go on issues let's let's let's do
that okay so when it comes down to
issues what is your position on drugs as
a libertarian what does a libertarian
think about with drugs
that our society would be much better if
we lifted these restrictions
and
you know i'd like to point out when's
the last time you heard of a liquor
store owner going up and down the halls
of a high school trying to push bourbon
or when's the last time you heard of a
vodka addict trying to break into a
house in order to support a vodka habit
part of the problem we have with drugs
is the illegality because there's a
profit in there
if if you're selling liquor which is
legal
now you don't have the profit motive to
try to sell it to kids
it's not worth it for the pennies
dollars you would make to end up in
prison it is however for the humongous
profits that we have
in illegal drugs and studies have shown
that when you make something illegal it
goes up in price by about 20 to 25 times
that's why we have the problems that we
have with so many of that when you make
something illegal the price goes up by
20 to 25 some people in california
would argue that to say in california
they made drugs legal but it was so
expensive like marijuana let's just say
but it was so expensive that drug
dealers were behind closed doors saying
listen you're paying that much for that
here come through me and i'll sell it to
you for this much so still give him an
out for it because
uh uh there was still you know
regulations to it but what you're saying
is
let's legalize marijuana let's legally
legalize heroin crack coke all of that
and let's let the market this well let
me point out according to milton
friedman we wouldn't even have crack
cocaine if it weren't for the illegality
because economically it would not make
sense to take cocaine and distill it
down to crack cocaine it's only because
there was such a profit margin that we
even have crack cocaine um and you know
i'm willing to say
uh well first of all i'd like to point
out that so many people were like oh
wait until marijuana is legal we're
gonna see you know
gangs in the street with ak-47s and
we're gonna have and we haven't seen
that what we've seen is basically
peaceful transactions
uh if if you want to do it step by step
that's fine but the longer we wait the
longer we're going to have young kids at
risk
by these horrendous drug dealers who are
in it just to make a profit for
themselves one of the bigger issues
you're seeing in california right now
though is that the illicit market or the
legal market for
marijuana is twice as big as the legal
one yes because
they haven't deregulated it because you
they're only allowing a few people to
sell it i mean what would happen if they
did that with alcohol you know there
were only a few people granted the right
to be able to sell alcohol we'd probably
still see bathtub gym and i'd also like
to point out some people say
well but
if everything were legal you know then i
might have a meth house next to me
uh and meth is danger and we all know
about meth houses right
that
it's it's toxic you can die from being
in the house because there's residue and
the house could blow up and it's just a
bad place for people to hang out
well
how many houses you know have you ever
heard of a gin house or a vodka house we
don't have bathtub gin being made
anymore so
if if it were legal
now instead of having a meth house next
to you you're going to have seagram's or
you're going to have you know
phil morris whoever you're going to have
some corporation making those drugs
uh
initially regulated
and
uh safely as opposed to next to you
you're not going to have the drugs
you're not going
it's it's going to look like alcohol
than it does right now so you mentioned
uh initially regulated but doesn't that
also go against traditional
libertarianism where you don't want the
government to intrude who would be
regulating them oh absolutely uh we have
to work within the system we have and
again there are so many reasons if we
look at the regulation what we see is we
see uh people getting special well first
of all
they get special tax breaks they get uh
they spend lobbying money and then uh
they get protection so no i i would want
to do away with that but
you can't just overnight have a
libertarian world so just like right now
we're starting with marijuana
we need like i said
uh the the quicker we can legalize
things and the quicker we can get the
drugs out of the hands of the young
school kids so the closest uh test that
we have is san francisco right because
in sanford i don't know if you've been
to san francisco i'm sorry the closest
what test like if you look at what's
really taking place right now with a lot
of uh
drugs that is more lenient san francisco
you got you've got oregon you've got a
couple of the markets but kraken kraken
is a company if you want to pull up that
article kraken
is a uh company this kraken ceo jesse
powell today issued a statement
regarding rampant crime in san francisco
and the failure of d.a
we shut down kraken's global
headquarters on march in san francisco
for numerous employees were attacked
harassed or robbed on their way and from
the office business partners were afraid
to visit
and were victimized crime mental illness
and drug abuse are out of control in the
city which is drastic dramatically
underreported because it's too
commonplace the police are known to
arrest the same offenders dozens of
times thanks to district attorney
k catch and release program
uh which has resulted in numerous
preventable murders of innocent people
san francisco is not safe and not be
safe until we have a d.a who puts the
right of law abiding citizens above
those of the streets criminals he's so
ingloriously protect so drugs
you know some may or may i respond to
that yeah but but a parent may a parent
may say
okay so let's just say we legalize it
all right so if we legalize crack heroin
all of that stuff where people can just
get it and you're saying
regulation not regulation
you're saying things like this will
minimize this is going to go away
what i would say is san francisco is the
opposite of a libertarian city it is a
socialist city that san francisco has
got to be one of the worst cities in the
entire country as far as as far as being
libertarian um
they've got uh i mean yeah it's
socialist what can i say and
no they they're not cracking down on
crime i mean i i don't
we can go into the whole crime spree
people walking out the door with eight
hundred fifty dollars worth of stuff how
do you think they know that how do you
how do you how do you address that like
if you were in san francisco right now
let's just say your
mayor yeah let's just say you're the
mayor what would you do
well first of all i'd make it illegal to
shoplift i would say i don't care if you
walk out with you know pack a gum that's
shoplifting now i wouldn't throw
somebody in jail for a pack of gum of
course but no it there it it there's
complete lawlessness in san francisco uh
and and
to me it is absurd that again you're a
small business owner mom and pop store
somebody walks out with um
800
and that's okay that's not okay and once
again we get to we've got laws that are
helping the big guys more than the small
guys walgreens who is closed i've lost
track now 14 stores at least
they can shut down 14 stores and then
have 49 other sane states
as well as parts of california that
might be sane and still earn a profit um
i have seen on tv so many people who you
know small
small company it's been open for
generations and now they've got to close
or they've got to move to another city
because they can't afford to have 800 of
stuff stolen or they can't afford you
know that's their only location they
can't say well we'll just you know keep
our virginia uh branch going so once
again we've got laws
that are are helping the big guy not the
little guy and politicians who just
don't care richard branson tom what was
it when richard branson a few years ago
said he thinks we should legalize heroin
and allow people to use heroin i don't
know if you remember that or not there's
been
there's been other people that have been
supportive of this position
i remember talking to uh oscar goodman
the mayor of vegas i think his wife is
now the mayor of vegas 21 years of
goodman's the 22 maybe 23 years the
goodness have been mayors of las vegas
and he talked about the same thing he
talked about the fact that if you
want to use heroin you want to use this
you want to use that go at it you had a
similar libertarian belief but okay so
let's set that part aside let's go to
trade trade with china trade with
different countries what is your view on
trade how different would your trade
philosophies be than what we have today
my trade philosophy is that people have
the right to trade their goods and
services with other people regardless of
where they are
and that when you throw tariffs in there
that's basically a hidden tax and people
pay more
uh you know let's go to bangladesh that
makes a lot of close
if we put tariffs
now poor people in this country
have to pay more for their clothes and
what we have is we have a government
that
puts all these regulations in place to
increase prices and then the government
says oh i guess we have to hand out
welfare well maybe if they got rid of
some of these regulations
we would have cheaper goods and services
and people would be able to buy things
at a reasonable or cheap cost so how
would you how would your relationship
with china be today how would you how
different would you treat china i hope i
hope i would have a very good uh
relationship with china as with other
countries what does that mean i mean
that's that's illegal well that means
yeah the the example that i like to give
is
uh japan
which is you know 1941 world war ii
horrible
they bombed us
and i point out you know we buy so many
hondas and toyotas now
uh they're not gonna bomb us now because
you tend to not bomb your best customer
so
when goods cross borders soldiers don't
have to so if you have a good trading
partner then why would you um you know
why would there be a problem because you
can help each other who do you see right
now as enemy enemy estate number one
like in america today so
you become president tomorrow who is
some countries that you'd be very
careful doing business with because
their motives may not align with our
motives
well but you have to look at the
leaders versus the people
so friends in saudi arabia years ago
president bush was like oh saudi you
know they're they're our friends well
yeah bush was friends with the king and
and you know the the the aristocratic
people in saudi arabia meanwhile the
other people are getting ready for 9 11.
so
uh if we can trade freely and people see
that it's an advantage and that they're
being helped by us
then
we would have a better relationship but
again
it's not a matter of
this ruler versus this ruler it's people
freely trading goods and
which kind of goes to
we talk about foreign oh but that's not
how things are you're saying people so
you so in order for you to your
philosophy to exist everybody in the
world would need to believe in what you
believe in it's not going to happen
you're saying for people to trade freely
with each other well i mean it doesn't
matter to me i shouldn't say it doesn't
matter to me it would be nice if china
could freely trade with switzerland but
you know that's their business all i'm
worried about is americans being able to
trade but in that case if we're freely
trading with china but anything
we we can they can export anything they
want here without any trades or tariffs
but the stuff we export there would we
then also have to not have a tariff on
that end or could they do whatever they
want in that case
when they end up doing that we end up
with more money in our pockets uh if if
they want to punish their people there's
nothing we can do about that what i want
to do is not punish our people i want
our people to be able to get the best
prices they can i think that's naive is
it is it i think in one thing there it's
more short-term versus long-term is it a
good thing in the short term but
something that could hurt in the long
term
how would it hurt people in the long
term i think if you're if you have if
you have export of goods and we're now
decreasing so you're flooding the market
with international products which is
good for the consumer it's cheap but in
the long term that consumer needs a job
and if we're exporting that and you
don't have tariffs or a way to protect
that what are we doing to protect the
workers in in our country though well
you know politicians let me give you an
example paul and if you don't mind i
need to get it please do that yeah
please can you do me a favor and pull up
uh
um
i'm sorry go for it i'll text you go
ahead so um
politicians talk about unforeseen
consequences and that's so frustrating
because
you know like san francisco saying we're
going to prosecute
uh
only 900 or 950 whatever dollars and
above oh we didn't see this coming i
mean no you should have seen it coming
so let's take cars
uh we protected detroit
and
what the what the government did
was they said don't worry we'll prop you
up we'll make sure that you know people
pay tariffs and
and so they got lazy and if you look at
what the unions were doing which was
just so frustrating the unions would say
oh well you hired us to put one screw in
over there not you know three screws
over here so we're not going to do it
and so car companies were unable to
innovate and so now you're still going
to this you're still going to the
dealership well i want the power windows
but not the power door locks and
meanwhile japan over there
which is really competing
they're the ones saying oh guess what
we're going to give you all that free so
basically we're propping up in industry
and and
you know hindering it because we're
we're protecting it from
free market forces
and
if if if the government had not
protected them then maybe they would
have been more competitive and they and
you know it would be like okay union we
don't care what you say you're putting
three screws over there or we're gonna
go get somebody else because we've got
to be able to compete with japan and i
teach in my uh social psychology class
that
competition is good and that's one of
the reasons and and there's a trade-off
but i won't go into the academic stuff
but
the reason that we're walking around
with such awesome phones like yours
right there is basically bill gates and
steve jobs hated each other and they
wanted to outdo each other and each one
came up well i'm going to do this and
then the next one i'm going to do that
and they were fiercely competitive and
were the ones who went out and part of
the reason that technology was able to
move as fast as it did is that the
government
couldn't keep up and
regulate it at every level you know when
it comes to cars that's
for you know like 80s 90s kind of low
stan low technology you've got cafe
standards you know mileage uh biden just
put in other mileages so we've got the
government hindering competition by
throwing all these things at them
computers were going so fast they
couldn't even keep up so i think that's
a good example of you're saying that the
government is hindering but if the
government is hindering how then would
not tariffs also
just ruin it even more because i think i
think you can either go away with all of
it and have it more competitive and kind
of go about that route or you can't just
take away certain things if you take
away if you take away tariffs without
taking away unions in that end which is
the opposite end of it right
either they have control or they have no
control so then at that point you're
just hindering more and just crushing it
more oh trust me under jorgensen
administration
the unions would not have the power that
they have now do i think that people
should be able to freely and
collectively get together and bargain
absolutely what i'm completely against
is the special
rules that unions get to where basically
unions can hold companies hostage so if
if you want to get together and
you
you unionize and you say we're going to
demand this and the company says
not we're going to hire you know another
thousand people
goodbye okay you know free in other
words free market union bargaining yeah
but but but let's go back to that uh in
regards to china it's very important
stay on china let's stay on china no so
it's why it's
because it's the country that wants to
take over u.s what do you mean why you
can't say why
as a candidate it's what most americans
fear the power and the motive that china
has they get up and talk about america
that they want to break to crush the
skull of anybody that gets in the way
and that's their foreign minister saying
that you're saying why but let me stay
on this let me let me ask my question
let me ask my question and then i'll
turn it over to you so
if i if i'm a voter whether i'm on the
left or the right i fear certain
countries okay
and uh if i'm uh i'm probably gonna fear
a little bit of iran i'm gonna fear a
little bit of russia but probably a lot
more today i'm gonna fear china
and then there's a few other countries
that i would fear right okay to say
yeah it's just give them trade i mean
it's just it's okay let them do trades
with us and as long as they're sending
us the product that's great well what
eventually happens is you eventually
rely on that country where 80 of the
chips
are being made there and the value of
cars goes to the roof
and you got china's coveted cases are
record-breaking as of today those are
china's covet cases john if you can show
that on the screen and if these guys get
coveted cases i don't know if you've
seen what china just did the entire
nation's been shut down so they're not
working now so i can't get chips out now
so now i have to delay the value of used
cars are about to go up another 10 20
percent china doesn't give a [ __ ] about
america china doesn't wake up in the
morning saying well joe jorgensen you're
libertarian philosophies are so sweet
we're gonna follow it as well and here's
what we're gonna follow they don't care
about us and and because of all these
relations we've had with them over the
last 40 years
we have made a country that was not in
the top 10 of gdp now number two is
about to pass up u.s
and they're now realizing the world
revolves around us u.s owes them 1.1
trillion dollars of debt and they got to
make those payments to them
if we're not it's naive to say that what
i do think we're libertarian would have
worked is if a country's
being founded so your philosophies work
if you go start your own country from
the beginning then i would move to it
but it is so hard to change the
infrastructure of a country like this to
say well let's do this well let's do
that but that also means the way we've
trained all these other powerhouse
countries in the world that we've
empowered they also have to change we're
naive if we think they're going to
change i'll turn it over to you well
there are about four or five questions
packed in there i would still point out
you said that china doesn't care about
us
japan cares about us now these are two
different countries i know but i keep
saying japan japan's not china i know
but my point is is that japan bombed us
earlier they wouldn't bomb us now
because we're buying a lot you know
what what would they do without us
buying all their toyotas and hondas it's
in their best interest
as i said when goods cross borders
soldiers tend not to but you talked
about chips
part of the reason that we've got so
many chips made in china is because of
the tax structure because of the unions
because of all the problems we've got in
the u.s
that if we could have more of a free
market here then we would have more
chips made here so
again i
i like to sometimes quote my running
mate in 1996 harry brown he said what
the government does is they break your
leg and then they expect you to be
grateful when they hand you crutches and
that's exactly what we're doing so we we
we've got so many taxes that
manufacturing has moved off but it's in
fact uh notice trump lowered that and
some people started coming back so you
know what if we put that at zero do you
think maybe there'd be chips made here
so
yeah that's why we're relying on china
for that oh my god if you go with the
approach of just being passive with
china they will
use and abuse you in capital they will
say i'm so glad a doctor joe jorgensen
is president because she is so sweet
let's take advantage of america it's
going to be so awesome for us because
look what russia did here's here's the
thing with russia right how do you think
russia views
biden versus a trump love hate whatever
you want to call trump or biden
russia or the world didn't do anything
under trump's administration okay
you didn't have any afghanistan issues
you had palestine and israel getting
along 25 years first time you didn't
have any of the stuff that was going on
with russia everybody was pretty chill
saying you know what maybe we don't need
to do anything then all of a sudden a
leader like biden gets in nice man seems
like a very nice man
i don't know his motives and all that
other stuff but when i look at him at
face value i'm like okay very nice what
happens boom taliban opportunity boomed
russia opportunity ukraine boom
everybody's like opportunity opportunity
uh look i i want to sit there and say
these things make sense
but there are some real legitimate
oppositions america has today
that we have to know how to manage them
okay
again going back to this
joe today
china shut down today
most of our air conditionings comes from
there most of the equipment we get from
there yeah again
we should be making that here but
because of the tax structure because of
the unions because of many other things
we're not and how about we solve that
problem so we can start bringing
manufacturing this brings me back to
this brings me back to
why you ought to consider running for
congress or senate instead of president
this brings me back to why don't you do
a you know working from the bottom
grassroots movement yeah grassroots
movements let's get some more senate
you're at the bitcoin conference why
don't you go inspire a ton of these guys
to go want to go be congressman and
congresswoman and mayors and governors
and senators i just did that yesterday i
talked with somebody who said he was
interested in libertarian and the way he
was talking i asked him well have you
considered running for office actually i
think i've asked two or three people
that but the guy i talked with yesterday
said you know i have been thinking about
that maybe mayor and i said you should
do that so and and we do need more
libertarians at the state and local
levels and our campaign one of our um
goals of our campaign
was to help people running for state and
local so for instance uh probably more
so than any other presidential campaign
what we would do is we would take the
data real time
give it to people who were running for
state and local offices
and
because in the past
many many different campaigns have
promised to give the information
and they would get them to them like a
year later after the election or not get
it to them at all but we were probably
the best in libertarian party history
for getting that information
to those people so they would have data
they could use so that they could try to
win their offices and we recently had a
libertarian voted into a state rep place
and we do have a couple of prominent
libertarians at the local level and i
think that that is very important
because so many people have never heard
libertarians or were the you know wild
crazy people with the horns and they can
see that we've got very good ideas that
work
and uh the people who have run the the
jeff hugh jim turner they've been doing
a great job
and
people have started saying you know what
this this actually does work you know
how about we do cut taxes how about we
do let people uh make their choice now
you gotta agree with cutting taxes right
you can't that's not the point though of
course i'm a capitalist of course i
agree with cutting taxes but for me it's
the all-in package it's not just one
area of cutting tax i can't even get in
with the drugs part okay fine let's just
say if i go oh we just you well the
reason i said that is because when i
said cutting taxes you kind of sighed
and i thought well that's common ground
now i can't agree on i'm i'm of course
i'm there but here's what i'm thinking
about i'm so consider me
from the angle i'm processing i can't
run for office i'm not born here if i
was born here i'd have a different
conversation but i can't so i can't
create that kind of change right myself
but but i'm talking more from your
standpoint of where you are
why isn't this message
that is somewhat a common sense
not trait not a few departure i have a
hard time with some of the parts of it
because you can never you can never
underestimate the power of an enemy that
wants to take you down never if you do
that you are so naive you don't belong
in office you can never underestimate
that and quite frankly i don't want to
have a leader that will underestimate
the enemy because they'll scare the crap
out of me for four years and i want that
person out of office as quickly as
possible i don't want that but i want to
go to another thing can i just say
something really quickly and then
and and the reason i was saying you know
can we move on because maybe this is an
agreed to disagree and there are so many
other topics i'd love to cover but in my
campaign i said that i wanted to turn
america into one giant switzerland armed
and neutral
absolutely i want a strong military
absolutely
uh
have our borders safe you know
absolutely uh
should be open you think people should
come in and out borders
borders should be protected from enemies
and so yes i want you know like i said
one giant switzerland
except lately they waited on the uk
crane thing but that's another thing so
uh no
i want a strong defense
so that i can protect america
um but you were going out you're you're
leading somewhere else
yeah so
where i was going with this um but since
you went there let's just kind of go to
the border side what do you what are
your thoughts about immigration should
people just cross the border and come to
america if they if they choose to
how should we treat illegal immigrants
crossing the border in the south
my position is
three of my grandparents are immigrants
they came over in the early 1900s
and that's what i'd like to see us go
back to which is pretty much open
borders
of course
we don't give them free phones
we don't give them free health care we
don't do all of that
and of course if we know you know
ms-13 gang members or
you know terrorists of course we don't
let them in
but
what made our country great is people
like my grandparents coming over here
and working hard for the american dream
and that's one of the reasons why i love
my country so much my grandmother when i
was younger used to tell me about the
old country about how you know the old
country they just take all your money so
everybody has the same and you can work
and work and work and you don't get
anywhere
and listening to her stories is really
what made me love this country so much
and she came over here worked very hard
and my grandfather worked very hard from
the same country although they met here
and by the way what's scary is the
country that she came from is denmark
and denmark
you know we don't think of it as
an oppressive country but she would tell
us how yeah they just take all your
money and here you can work hard and
earn a living and by the way when they
died it's not like they had amassed a
huge fortune in fact they uh lived in
florida and lived in why i used to call
it a trailer she would correct me and
say a mobile home
and
but but the thing is is she said in
america you can live how you want and
you can work hard and make something of
yourself open borders
open borders again i'm not going to let
terrorists come across how are you going
to figure out who's a terrorist and
who's not do i look like a terrorist
what if i come don't we no don't we know
don't we don't we keep trying are they
is there going to be an ice would there
be a border patrol workers to come
through would they have to id them so
what do you mean by open border would
there not be a wall would there not be a
fence would there not be anything for
people to come across like i said like
the early 1900s when we when we had more
people come in
i mean now it's the opposite
yeah but but okay so let me get this
part right i want to really understand
this so
if i go if i'm saying i'm coming from
tijuana
what am i crossing if i'm coming from
tijuana
is there a gate is there border patrol
is there an ice in your world in your
administration
this gets into
something that's controversy on the
libertarian party because there are many
who say yes we want to gate and others
who say no
so
i would prefer to have it
so that we have
minimal checking
here's one of the biggest problems that
we have right now is that
you know because so many people say well
uh people just need to come over legally
but
the system is set up so that hardly
anybody can come over legally so i would
like to flip it around so we've got more
people than not being able to pass
through but
you know we've got national security
people who know who
some terrorists are they know who the
gangs are so god joe you sound naive
again you can't say that so so let me go
back to it i don't mean to offend you
please i don't mean to be disrespectful
but oh no i like i like spirit
so so but go back to the border so you
didn't answer the question i i want as
clear of an answer on this one as
possible because would we have an ice
and border patrol under a
jorgen jorgensen administration or would
anybody be able to drive by and come to
us
can i answer that if i'm a candidate
again
will you have me back if i'm a candidate
no i want to hear it now because because
i'm not a candidate no but but if but if
you were if you're on the stage by the
way i'm not even a moderator i'm not
even asking questions on the debate if
you can't answer the question to a guy
like me
i want to hear it from you because i
think the audience would want to know we
have a lot of your followers and we have
people
who are
considering
a lot of people who call themselves
libertarian that now are like
dude i'm not down with that that just
completely threw me off well yeah and
see that's what i'm getting the
up until recently the libertarian party
platform
was that we only let people across the
border
who are not going to take away your life
liberty or property
and now it's become more open borders so
that's why i'm saying
uh there's some serious discussion in
the libertarian party and my
my um
promise to the libertarian party was
that i would uphold the platform
and i do like the idea of only letting
people across with um
who believe in life liberty and property
that they're not going to take those
from uh so so would you have a border
patrol would you have do we verify that
now if i come through today if i go to
tijuana which i've gone to many times
when i was 18 years old if i'm coming
back there'd be a line of cars and
there's a fence that i have to cross
time you've gone through this before
when you go to tijuana absolutely
there's a fence and what do they do
can we see idea of everybody in the car
how about how about making it wider so
the line's not so long first of all
i think this is a very serious issue joe
i want to go back to what you're saying
though
what is in under your administration
what does that border look like if
somebody is coming
from central or south america because
their country has a lot of problems
they're escaping whatever regime they're
going through they're escaping the
mexican cartel they're trying to come to
america or the isis is trying to figure
out a way to come through the border
because americans are being politicians
they're being naive and they open up the
border to say oh we're just an open
border type of place and isis will say
what a naive bunch of people let me get
in there this is an easy way for me to
get in under your administration that
would be open i would suggest that we
have better um
national intelligence that we don't know
you know that that we don't know who the
dangerous people
we're not going to get everybody but
we're not going to get everybody who are
homegrown terrorists either i mean we've
got a timothy mcveigh who was born on
the soil so
it's never going to be
you never have utopia but what i'm
asking you is would your borders be open
would it look like going from florida to
georgia no
what would it look like
it would look like
everybody who comes across
if national security has said that this
person shouldn't come across it's going
to be more like 99 coming across so what
we have now we just had two million
border crossings last year but the
problem that we have now we've got two
problems now
we've got
uh
we
we've got an impossible system to become
a legal immigrant uh there's there's uh
low quotas
people have to go through uh too much
paperwork
secondly
when they come here we've got a welfare
state
that
uh
you know that we say okay we can pick up
on them although
well two things
first of all
yeah i don't like this whole phone idea
i don't know why we're giving people
free phones yeah they're giving they're
giving them phones instead of ankle
bracelets guys i want to simplify this
it's very simple i want to talk borders
let's stay on borders what happens if a
libertarian candidate is the president
what does the borders look like oh that
that's what i'm telling you i'm going to
let 99 percent of the people go
but to come in but 99
yes so we'd have similar numbers like
two million three no it'd be even higher
than that yeah um it would be like when
my grandparents came across which is
what helped make our country great uh
but i would like to go back to the
charity because i said i don't you know
i don't like the fact that we've got so
many um
uh
welfare programs that they can come back
that they can come in and take advantage
of
however many of them are set up so that
somebody has to be here one year two
years five years depending on what it is
depending on if it's state or local
depending on if it's from one state to
another
i don't believe that many of these
people are coming across the border
just for our welfare i think many of
them are coming across for the very
reason that my grandparents came across
which is to work hard and make a better
life for themselves
i i think i i still don't have an answer
though that's what i'd like to go ahead
tom joe respectfully
you know in your answers here you're
pointing back to some very real issues
okay
so we have quotas we have h1b quotas for
professional knowledge workers we also
have
certain uh quotas for total immigration
yeah those are things are going on now
but if you were president you know damn
well that an executive order you could
sign on day one you can move those
numbers the question
really is and i would and i would and
what people want to hear is what does
open border mean specifically
for you the libertarian president
and if you could answer that again i'm
letting in 99 percent of the people she
just did and and through intelligence
i'm going to have somebody stopping
somebody that we know
um is a murderer
somebody who uh
you know that we know
is a terrorist from the middle east
somebody that's a gang how are you gonna
know like can you read my okay what
number am i thinking right now
again but what i'm trying to say is how
do you know anybody's motives how do you
know like like are we going to have a
born identity not border identity
minority to rapport technology to know
who's about to create a future crime and
arrest people on future crimes
you don't know you don't you don't
even today we don't have that kind of
intelligence to track all of that but i
can say the same thing
how do we know that timothy mcveigh was
going to go and bomb people um there are
dangerous people in this country as well
uh you can't know every motive but you
can know who gang members are in mexico
right emma's thirteen so you know them
so so then that that that then goes to
if we already have so many problems like
a timothy mcveigh in our country why
don't we close the borders and make the
requirements clear
but a little bit more picky on who we
hire a company who just hires anybody
and everybody into the company without a
filtering system
whoever that hiring person is in that
company should be fired because there's
got to be certain criterias on how you
hire people right such as
you want me to give you some of them
yeah it's very easy i want to know what
your experience is i want to know what
kind of qualifications you got i want to
know so i want to know what you bring to
the table i want to know how you're
going to make my company better i want
to know how many jobs you've had in the
last five years and how many times
you've changed i want to know what your
attendance is i want to call your three
references i want to put a small
challenge to you in the interview
process and tell you joe i like your
attitude i like the way this is going do
you like to read books i do i want you
to read this book
write a paper on it into this third
interview i want to see what you get out
of this book you're willing to do that
sure if you don't come back 50 of the
time you don't finish a small assignment
like that you're not going to finish a
small assignment when you're hired with
me i just filtered out the people that
don't want to do the work i would filter
those people out instead saying come on
in everybody let's hire everybody so why
don't we just hire 200 people forget
about hiring anybody let people apply to
work for this company and don't even
interview them just bring them all in
that just the logic behind even i'm
thinking purely logically as an operator
i can't logically i should have never
like if i think about myself at a
certain age you should have never hired
me because i was not qualified to be
hired so we should let anybody through
the border okay so let me go we can we
can agree to disagree and get to a more
interesting topic yeah well this is a
very interesting topic and by the way a
lot of people are worried about this
specific topic yeah except i don't think
we're going to get anywhere no but but
but i think but what i do think a lot of
people are here
saying you know
you know uh
there is an answer to that i want to
know what the position is for the
libertarian party on how they manage
that but you didn't just get like 10 000
votes you didn't get 20 000 votes you
got 1.8 so the way you got one pointed
i'm trying to think
did you guys get 1.8 because there's 1.8
million libertarians in america is it
just talking to the base of people that
agree with you or you don't talk to
people
that maybe challenge the position and
break it down where the others can make
up their mind and say well this makes
sense or this doesn't make sense because
that also gets your argument to be
stronger to say well listen i just sat
down with this guy he asked that
question i don't have an answer for it
guys we got to be ready because
someone's going to ask me this question
under the election we got to get watch
this clip here's how i answered it you
should have said this this is the
position got it let's role play so
that's how i would train my candidate if
i'm their campaign manager but let's go
through another topic i have two
questions on immigration before that you
mentioned that uh
hold that thought
it i want to ask this one question and
then i'm going to come back to you so
selling stuff
what what shouldn't be sold legally
what should be illegal to sell
what list would you come up with i'm
asking you i mean people well people
shouldn't be sold okay so prostitution
under libertarianism
no no that
no pimping would be illegal
that's not the same thing as selling
selling would be slavery selling people
would be slavery prostitution
is
voluntary so pimping is fine
not the pimping we have right now and
that's the whole problem that's why we
have the problems with pimping right now
is because it's not legal if you look at
a place where it is legal like in nevada
certain parts of nevada right
you don't have the stis you don't have
the pimps beating up the women you don't
have a lot of the dangerous problems
going on
and
why should why should it be illegal
okay so pimping should be illegal under
you keep saying pimping
that's i'm seriously afraid
no but i'm being specific i'm a person
how about prostitution i'm asking you
prostitution should that be legal
absolutely it's your body do whatever
you want to do with it but well not if
you're going to hurt somebody else but
if you're going to have a consensual
relationship with somebody else and get
paid for it that's totally fine
i don't discriminate against ugly people
i mean
some guys maybe they couldn't get a hot
chick without that
why shouldn't they have the same things
as somebody who has money or looks there
you go okay so what should be illegal
what should be illegal to be sold
uh do you want to give me a list because
no first of all nobody's ever asked me
that question secondly i can't think of
of any inanimate object that would
qualify so let's just say elon musk has
got 300 billion dollars he wants to go
buy a nuclear bomb should it be legal
that question is so ridiculous
um i guess it depends on how dangerous
of the neighborhood he lives in you know
no but but but but you you but you what
is that is that really on the top 10
concerns of voter's
is definitely one of them and you wanted
to skip that because you didn't think
it's a big deal china was one of them
and he said can we go to another topic
that's one of their top 10 issues now
i'm trying to get a little bit more
different because i'm saying what prod
because because let's just say crack
should be legal what can i just can i
tell you real quick please real quick
okay we didn't skip china we just got to
a stalemate i gave you my japan answer i
gave you my chips and three powers china
i know but uh but yeah again you keep
mentioning crack
we wouldn't even have crack if it if
cocaine hadn't been illegal according to
nobel prize winning economist uh milton
friedman so
what shouldn't what can and can't be
sold
what age can certain things be sold
is there is there a limit on that
alcohol now is 21 here it's 18 in most
other countries drugs legalization is
there a certain age where you can or
can't and who says that and what's the
process of making sure that that's
followed well i'm fine with 18 and i'd
like to point out the reason that it's
21 is elizabeth dole because
uh basically if
uh
a state
the residents would send their money to
the federal government
and the only way for them to get it back
would be for bribery to occur which is
okay you're only getting your money back
that's your money by the way
if you raise your drinking age to 21 why
shouldn't different states have
different laws in which um
you know one state's 18 another one's 21
and others 20.
[Music]
so you know competition among states but
what we have with the federal government
is one size fits all where we don't get
much choice but no i'm not having you
know an age limit of five on alcohol
that's ridiculous i
18 is
uh pretty reasonable and what about
drugs
i mean
18 across the board is fine with me and
is would that also be a country thing or
is it more a state or even like a city
county yeah states i mean there are dry
counties and what happens if you are
on vacation in a different state and
you're breaking the law like for
instance if you there's there's cases of
people who have marijuana they they live
in california they go to some place
where it's not legal you get caught like
what's the ramifications there how does
that look like
well
i just as we ended alcohol prohibition
nationally
i would like to end marijuana
prohibition nationally
so that you don't have that with that
though if one county or one state says
we don't want to are you then limiting
that they have to or is it more a well
if you don't want to then you don't have
to
again i think people have the right to
make their choice i mean notice we're
not having this conversation on alcohol
we're not saying you know well what if
um
you know mississippi wanted to outlaw
alcohol and i'd like to point out and i
i know from
my job
that
marijuana is a heck of a lot safer than
alcohol
and so
again we've got a
um a system
in which the politicians they prefer
alcohol so they make their drug legal
why not make other people's drugs legal
joe just said accuracy who have you
debated who's been your toughest debate
ever
i mean
i didn't feel that any of my debates
were tough i've owned
i
i'm
yeah
who have you debated
in 1996 i was in the third party debate
when i debated the green party
constitution party and and those
uh in march before
the nomination
i was also in a third party debate where
i sat next to the green party
nominee and a few other people
and then of course the debates within
the libertarian party
but when's the last time you had a
really tough debate against a
non-libertarian
when is it
it was pretty easy uh debating the green
party candidate that's for sure um
so
yeah let me continue when is the last
time you had a debate with a
non-libertarian or non-green party
when's the last time you had a debate
with somebody that was non-libertarian
non-green well an official debate like i
said it would be in the nomination
process in 2020
20 19 20. would you debate
well as i said
the green party i don't remember who all
was on the stage
uh some of them are parties i'd never
heard of but i have heard of the green
party and then um in 2020 it was within
the party
so you've never debated anybody that's
uh opposing libertarian or green party
well i mean again like if i go i'm going
to imagine party
i want to google it right now i'm on
youtube right now if i type in joe
jorgensen debate
what would you say is the part debate
that you had
that
was either a democrat or republican or
an independent oh there was a democrat
or two in the debate in chicago in
march yeah i guess it would have been
march 2020.
who who were they when you debated them
i don't remember their names was it
was it a stage debate was it public was
it oh yeah it was in it was in chicago
and what was the format what was the
format of the debate
uh
we would go down the line and answer
questions and get to respond to each
other but that's not a debate though so
you've never well
i mean you know it's not like the
lincoln douglas were debated so it
wasn't but
are you planning on running in 2023 2024
i don't know okay so let's just say you
are
uh
who who is your who is your like
um
who
behind closed doors are they sitting
there and like you know going back and
forth to assets you say this if they say
this you say this like who does that
with you guys back and forth debating do
you guys practice a lot of that
well since i was in no debates in
after the nomination we didn't do it uh
we were invited to the third party
debate however
i we were on the ballot in all 50 states
and
so
i did not want to debate
the other parties because
that would get us into comparison with
them as opposed to the democrats and
republicans
if i debated the green party then for
the next four weeks i'd have uh
reporters asking me to compare you know
what what about this on the debate stage
and now compare this
and the libertarian party is the only
party other than the democrats and
republicans to be on the ballot in all
50 states
uh there and so
i i'm not going to debate the green
party or kanye west who's on 16 states i
actually probably would get you more
eyeballs if you debated kanye west i
think that would be a good debate that
actually might not be a bad idea but
going back to it so
um
so debating you so who's been your
toughest interview
who has interviewed the toughest and
pushed you where you got off saying what
a son of a [ __ ]
in the past yes
toughest interview ever
where you couldn't wait to finish the
interview
oh that would have been in 1996 when i
was running for uh vp and i interviewed
somebody in ohio but i don't remember
the guy's name it's a long time ago it
is it's a long time ago that's like
saying you want to be a heavyweight
champion today but the last time you
fought a heavyweight was 26 years ago
you know how tough that is well no you
didn't ask when's the last time i fought
a heavyweight
that was the last time because i wasn't
as prepared in 1996. so who's the last
heavyweight you fought who's your last
heavyweight oh like who interviewed me
yeah who's the toughest interview you've
had recently well but again i wouldn't
call it tough but uh you know
the washington
post i mean i i did i got interviewed by
several media people but
i didn't consider them tough yeah so uh
okay so so for me the reason why i asked
that question is because
um
i said i've sat with other libertarians
and for somebody who politically was on
a different side and i sit down let me
hear the libertarian argument
and
you know i'm like oh okay that makes
sense okay well you know what that's a
good point you got me thinking oh wow
okay you know what never thought about
it i never looked at drugs that we've i
never looked at prostitution that way
before i never looked at you know
stealing that way before interesting
okay cool it made me think right
and and i don't feel i asked well so
the meth house didn't make you think
the idea that okay if we had phil morris
making meth instead of the guy next door
that that would be safer isn't that
maybe something you haven't heard
and we didn't get into prostitution but
hey i think that was pretty unique
saying that i don't want to discriminate
against ugly guys i mean right now to do
it legally you have to have money or you
have to be good-looking right
to get the woman that you want with her
looks are you are you i think that too
are you open to feedback can i give
feedback okay
so if if i if i wanted to give you
feedback
here's what i would do
i would sit you down
in a room like this
for four weeks straight
and i would grill the hell out of you
until you were throwing stuff at me oh
absolutely yeah and you would throw
stuff at me because i know how to do
that yes and you would say pat i need a
break i'd say no prom go forward take a
break come back okay
dr joe we role play this i'm gonna ask a
question one more time what are your
points boom
and i would i would go back and forth
back and forth back and forth because
there's a difference between the big
stage and between debating other
libertarians i mean what is the debate
with a libertarian look like okay i
agree with him yeah i agree with him but
i also agree with him but what i would
say is this but i think the age is 19
but i think they should be 18 but i
think the border should be this but i
think that but i agree but i agree but i
agree i mean the most important one time
we had a debate uh uh tyler who was the
debate we had with the two marijuana
folks that we had here debating yeah and
then no no it wasn't even that it was
that the beta had between alan
dershowitz and the other gentleman who
wrote the vaccine and then 20 minutes
into i'm like guys why don't we just
finish this debate and guys go have
dinner together because every word is i
agree i agree i agree nobody wants to
see something like that people want to
learn on opposing ideas to sit there and
say that doesn't make any sense okay so
how do you let's change the subject how
do you feel president biden's doing so
far oh
awful tell me why almost couldn't be
worse
go right down the list
the masks
uh
well first of all the fact that
he basically thinks he's king
for
everybody for every decision the fact
that he thinks he can tell schools what
to do
uh the fact that he's given fauci so
much power
that he's shutting down businesses that
he's uh printing up money handing out
checks i i i can't think of anything
he's done right the only thing that i
would have done that he did
was withdraw the troops
but i certainly wouldn't have taken
the soldiers out first and left the
civilians that doesn't even make sense
so the one thing that i agree with him
on he totally screwed up i i can't think
of anything he's done right what did you
like what trump did did trump do
anything right
yes he did
reduce some regulations
um
he
yeah reducing regulations reducing taxes
now of course you know the debt and the
um deficit we're getting into obama
territory but
uh
yeah
deficit oh and and i did like his pick
for the supreme court
which one which one
no amy
yeah um i like
i
i would have a hundred times picked
her over our most recent one okay so so
libertarian let's talk about transgender
where
you know the conversation with disney
saying you know
sex ed by third grade and you know after
third grade we do sex ed and then uh uh
i think gen saki has said if you want to
put out what jim sackey said yesterday
about transgender i don't know if you
saw that or not uh uh put uh gen saki
uh
transgender
uh
yesterday briefing yeah if you can huh
software news yeah software news uh it
wouldn't be march 31st go back to it
because it was yesterday it's april 7th
i want to say just type in news yeah uh
press briefing process
uh they're not even gonna put it up
there aren't they so ridiculous can you
zoom in a little bit to see if we have
it yeah let me let me find it okay you
find it but meanwhile what is your
position with disney coming out and then
uh uh disney's saying that 50 of their
characters moving forward within 12
months are going to be part of the lgbtq
community what what's your thoughts on
that
well disney's a private company and it's
a public company
i mean i'm sorry well i mean it's not
the government okay okay i mean it's
it's the free market as opposed to
government
so
they can do whatever they want and their
customers can do whatever they want and
i've heard many people say that we are
not going to
continue to put our money into disney
and i don't like what they're doing
but
can i step back to the bigger
transgender issue because this is
another issue in which
i think both the democrats and the
republicans
are basically wrong
on the republican side
many republicans
are saying you know well first of all
people are confusing sex with gender
and to use a you know shorthand method
genders between the ears sexes between
the legs so
and yes
it is possible and i'm teaching this in
class right now
it is possible to have
the genitalia that do not match
because of hormones
prenatally especially around the sixth
and seventh week so
the republicans
[Music]
act as though
there's no such thing as being
transgender that you're basically just
cross-dressing which is a different
thing
the democrats on the other hand act like
25 of the population is transgender and
now we've got to change all of our laws
i mean it's less than one percent it's
one out of a thousand people are
transgender
so
um there is a
a sane place in the middle
where we can say yes a very very small
minority of people are transgender
um
and
why do we need to make laws about that
and oh well and see this gets back to
the don't say gay thing
that gets
more into
parents
not having choice over their schools
and i can tell you that before age 10
kids are not thinking about
any kind of sex they
they don't understand being attracted to
another person
even heterosexual eight-year-olds are
not thinking about heterosexual sex so
why are we teaching why are they
teaching
homosexual sex to eight years old to
eight-year-olds it doesn't make any
sense but instead of having a law what
we need to have are schools that parents
can
um choose to send their kids to in which
the parents decide and i do think that
parents would overwhelmingly say what do
you mean you're teaching my
seven-year-old about homosexual sex
that's just not even on the radar so jen
sackey says a sex reassignment surgery
puberty blockers for kids it's best
practice
states states preventing it will be held
accountable so for you no that's
horrible
is the libertarian position let the
person do whatever they want to do with
their body or you know if a
nine-year-old wants to change their
sex that should be okay what would your
position be with that
it
the research is so clear
that
you should not do sex reassignment
before age 16 18
at least
many kids it it it really can be a phase
in fact i just said that gender
dysphoria is about one out of a thousand
in the population
some recent polls have shown that two
percent of high school kids think that
they're transgender okay that can't be
right so these are some people who think
they are but they're not and so i
believe that good medicine would win out
in this case that if you go to a medical
doctor who's trained and who has read
the research they're not going to give
you gender reassignment surgery but the
problem we have now is once again the
government is over overstepping and
they're basically telling doctors you
have to do this and and what you know
has jen saki gone in medical school has
she read the research has biden read the
research so why do we have people who
are politicians making these decisions
let's take some callers let's take some
callers john did you have a question yes
so real quick uh i i will never forget
uh ron paul getting absolutely grilled
by bill buckley uh on the libertarian
party and their stances so i
you were talking earlier about uh having
the cia have information on people who
may come across the border or ice or my
my question is what is your stance or
the libertarian party's stance on
organizations like ice nhs the cia the
fbi uh the f would you have an fda would
you keep these organizations abolish
them would it be case by case how would
would you privatize everything
what would be your stance on that uh
yes many of them would be about so let
me mention the fda specifically
uh
i'm fine with how i mean first of all i
think a free-market fda kind of
organization would be much better than
being under the government because
nothing works better under the
government than it does in the free
market
and let me give you an example of that
we've got
let's say uh
going
if you and let me go broader okay
in the government
you can screw up
and it's not going to cost you you know
because i've had people say well what
about osha what about having people out
there regulating
well if you look at things like yelp or
the mobile restaurant guide or zagat
they are going to put out
the best information they can because if
they say this restaurant is five stars
and you go there it sucks you're going
to stop using them you're gonna stop uh
giving them money but the government
can't go out of business so you can be a
safety inspector in fact i've talked to
a few people on the campaign trail who
said oh yeah i worked in chicago and
they basically gave me a hard hat and
gave me forms and they said just go and
ask the people to sign them like
basically don't even look because what
happens if you don't look you know the
government's not going to go out of
business
so rather than the fda which is
protected by the government which you
can't fire them i'd rather the free
market get rid of the people get rid of
the organizations who do not do well
so now if you want to keep an fda as an
advisory role okay but not having them
make legislation and that's one of the
problems is we've got like the fda we've
got the cdc that are now becoming
legislators as i said with the cdc
coming around and saying that
uh yeah don't don't evict anybody from
your apartment what
they're not elected and and
they shouldn't have the right to do that
anyway if anything
eviction
uh laws should be done at the state and
local level not the federal level uh my
position is is if you're not in the
military you should have almost zero
contact with the federal government that
it should be run state and locally
let's take some callers let's think
there's some people that want to really
talk so let's take some callers john if
you're ready
uh let us know who you got and we'll go
through it we have raul on the phone
raul how are you
i'm good how are you fantastic so raul
what's on your mind what question do you
have for uh dr joe
awesome so i am a young entrepreneur
worker uh so i don't have any interest
in getting into colleges well well i'm
curious as to what advice joel would
give to a young person looking at
getting into policy
oh a young person getting into politics
yeah so a lot of reporters asked me when
did you first become interested in
politics and my answer was i'm still not
interested in politics i'm doing this as
self-defense because the government is
taking over i'd rather be home gardening
to me anybody who says they want to get
into politics
that concerns me because usually people
who want to get into politics want to
make laws they want to tell their people
what to do so
typically
people who are freedom fighters and want
to restore freedom they're not asking
about being a politician
if if you're a freedom fighter and you
want to get out there
yeah i would say go to the local
libertarian group and talk with them
okay next raul good question let's go to
the next person johnny
yeah we have jake jake how you doing
jake
hey pbd uh good morning
good morning from denver
fantastic what's on your mind jake yes
sir so
uh
getting on the uh the live feed here
uh anytime i
come across uh libertarian i can't help
but to uh think of uh dr ron paul
and uh his run with uh i guess his 08
and 2012
uh campaign
any anything libertarian i always come
across like uh i guess in the fed and
i'd like to know
uh your take on
ending the fed
if you want to increase competition
cryptocurrency
back our currency up by gold uh how
would you go about that thank you thank
you take my call in fact the reason i'm
the reason yeah thank you the reason i'm
here is i'm at the bitcoin convention
and so many people have asked me do you
want to go back to the gold standard and
my answer is i don't think that goes far
enough that
monopolies don't work and
uh part of the problem that we have with
paper money is joe biden can come along
and say i'm going to send everybody a
1400 check but there there's not 1400
there to give to everybody so they go on
print which gives us inflation and there
are basically two ways you can tax
people you can either
raise taxes in which people see it and
they often complain because they see
their paychecks lower or
you can cause inflation
and then you're put in a higher tax
bracket and you don't realize how that's
how that money is being taken out of
your pocket so i would like to see free
market money the way that we have
free market and other things and you
know even go back to back in the olden
days when people couldn't pay their
doctor they would come in with chickens
right so hey if you want to accept
chickens as currency that should be your
right
somebody just gave a super chat the
username is no one know thyself gave 25
and said i voted for gary johnson in
2016. you lost my vote when you endorsed
blm after all the writing and looting
stemming from their protests how could a
libertarian be in favor of an
authoritarian organization intimidating
innocent people
not once
did i endorse blm
uh the organization
and no
rioting goes against every single
libertarian principle out there because
you're taken away life liberty and
property so
uh
they are not
uh
a libertarian organization quite the
opposite now i was criticized when i
said we shouldn't be racist
and
you know keep in mind
the george floyd incident happened what
four days after i got the nomination
so that's what everybody was asking
about that was the topic one thing i do
agree with with black lives matter is
that there is a problem
and so i'm willing to speak to people
who at least see there's a problem now
here's the the big thing though
and and it kind of breaks my heart
because i see these people at black and
black lives matter going to the
government to try to solve their
problems but government is the one that
created those problems and i tried to
spread the message that rosa parks was
riding a government-run government-owned
bus that in a free market you know let's
and and by the way at the time that
happened something like 70 of the bus
ridership was black now let's say uber
discriminated against the best 70 of
their customers they'd go out of
businesses while they should it's only
because
the um
government
uh
could run
a racist system
the government as i said with the fda
with everything else can't go out of
business so that's why we need the
competition so
no black lives matter uh
like i said i agree with them that
there's a problem
i
asking for more government is the
complete opposite direction you're not
against protesters like you supported
them as protesting
not rioting and burning down buildings
and all that absolutely not uh
going out into the streets
with signs that's fine
you want to put that article up john
because i think that's what this is
talking about oh okay yeah yeah if you
want to put this up yeah but notice
opportunistic people hijacking the
movement i mean i heard instances in
which
there were peaceful black lives i i'm
trying to think of where this happened
it was a starbucks in portland i think
i don't remember the exact city but
there were and and somebody got this on
tape there were black lives matter
people there protesting and then there
were the white antifa people coming in
and they were saying oh we got to get
this going we and and they start
um
uh
vandalizing a starbucks and and the
black lives matter people are saying no
no no that's not what we want to do
you know go away you're not helping so
uh
i don't care who it is
antifa black lives matter you know the
local garden party uh the local garden
club
absolutely
rioting burning down buildings
that's uh the opposite of libertarian so
let me ask a question because i think
this goes to what the caller is saying
is some maybe confusion about
libertarian party if you go the average
person on the street who doesn't dive
into mountains and mountains of articles
and get them wrapped up you say what's a
democrat oh that's the party of the
little guy
gay marriage minorities you know helping
people get welfare
aren't the democrats for the little guy
i'm just talking about an uninitiated
man on the spree then republic so what's
a republican oh their favorite business
and and low taxes and things like that
so even the uninitiated person on the
street is going to understand a couple
things
what
what what are the brand tenants or the
two core flags that are easy to remember
and easy to articulate
that the libertarian party's trying to
put out there because there seems to be
a lot of confusion about what your
stances really are which goes to you
need to be better at projecting the
message so what are those little things
that you would have people remember
oh yeah well it looks like yeah if you
if you want to be about big business and
low taxes because of the value that's
republicans you want to be about the
little guy in gay marriage and
minorities that's democrats we are this
individual liberty and personal
responsibility which means what if if
that you are allowed to make your own
choices so you have the individual
liberty to send your kids to the school
you want get the kind of health care you
want uh get the kind of retirement you
want but on the other hand
you've got the
responsibility
that you are responsible for your
choices
so
if you know if you don't save enough
uh the government's not going to rescue
you where you're you're going to rely on
charity that uh you need to make
but do you mind if i go back this is one
of the thing that frustrates me the most
if you wouldn't mind my um
is that
unfortunately the democratic party has
been given the um
uh accolades that now we have marriage
equality that now gays can get married
ten years ago both hillary clinton and
barack obama were against gay marriage
it was the libertarian party who even
back in the 1970s said people should be
able to marry whoever they want to marry
and so
uh and and it's
how you categorized it
is how i would have categorized it maybe
40 years ago in the 1980s when people
would ask me what a republic or what a
libertarian is i would say we take the
best of both sides and i would say for
instance we take the best of the
democratic party in that we believe that
you should be able to marry whoever you
want to marry and and so forth
we take the best the republican side you
should be able to hire whoever you want
to hire fire whoever you want to fire we
put those together but you can't say
that anymore i mean uh the democratic
party is no longer the democratic party
i remember from the 1960s they were the
anti-war pro-peace party and now look
trump
uh says he wants to bring you know have
troop withdrawal who are the first
people to criticize him the democrats
and so now we've gotten to the point to
where it's no longer the left is
protecting personal liberty in fact
they're the biggest fascists they're the
they want to censor everybody and
uh republicans
they're free spending almost as bad as
the uh
as the democrats so now it really is the
red team and the blue team and
whatever trump wants to do
democrats are automatically saying no no
no we can't do that and then biden wants
to do something and the republicans on
that automatically know we can't do that
but if you look
um
trump had some very
you know what was historically
what historically belonged to the
democrats
ending war
and
and here the democrats are fighting that
so i have a question regarding that
because uh in many ways it seems like
the how you're explaining it is in terms
of
individual uh freedom and then uh more
collective in terms of you can kind of
do what you want and more freedom on
that end i think that's a more vague
concept and an idea that we i'd say
probably most people could support
hypothetically theoretically awesome i
want to have more liberty and i can
decide what i am and i also have the
responsibility of that now what the
second thing you said is how the parties
have shifted right so don't you think
that in that case you need to shift the
way the libertarian party looks as well
because you can't say well we're a
little bit of that and a little bit
because a big thing with people vote how
many people voted for biden because they
didn't want donald trump how many people
voted for donald trump because they
didn't want biden no so so if it's a i'm
voting for this because i don't want
that in a two-party system then that's
where you are so how are you going to
then position yourself as a third party
of don't vote for that don't vote for
that because this is what we are so
kind of the way i look at it is the
biggest problem with a libertarian
especially the libertarian party is i
see them as the
get rid of the government get rid of
most of things which in that case is
like okay then we're just living in a
tribe we
meet in other words we could go to
montana and just set up tents and and
live among ourselves so it needs to be
something that's a little bit more
confined and say here are the three
things we do which is different and here
are the things things we don't do
because that way people can say this is
what we are and this is what we aren't
because a big thing if even if you look
back at any third attempt of a third
party throughout basically the last
hundred years is nobody really knows
what the third party is except that it's
not the
republican party or it's not the
democratic party even teddy roosevelt
couldn't create a party that's bigger
than him because once he stepped away it
was it was teddy roosevelt's party it
wasn't here what here's the foundation
of what we believe either get on it or
get off it was more hey we want to see
teddy roosevelt in office and we want
him to do his thing so let's vote for
them but you need to create something
that's bigger than one person in that
case
you brought up several excellent points
so
yes you're right i can we can no longer
say good good part from the right good
part from the left and like i said i
used to say that in the 80s i don't say
that anymore because because you can't
um and i would like to you know i'm
criticizing criticizing the republican
party but i would like to point out that
i look at republican politicians
and the party separate from republican
voters and in fact my 1996 stump speech
was why republican politicians keep
selling out freedom and i would talk
about the many fine republican voters
who want smaller government but the
politicians keep giving them bigger
government so very frustrating such as
um even ronald reagan but yes something
the libertarians have been very bad at
is
for many years we said what we were
against
you know valshas about that and this and
that instead of saying what we were for
and the other problem that we've had is
it almost we almost put ourselves out
there as an exclusive club and if you
don't answer every question right then
you're not pure enough to be a
libertarian
you know very philosophical and
we need to let in people i say let in
people that even that was you know old
libertarian uh language
uh
we need to bring in people
who do want
something that's different from now
people who do want
some liberty and
being able to make their own choices
and that's one of the things that we're
doing with people for liberty so
uh we're never going to get anywhere if
we keep doing the same thing in the
party which is
you can only come in if you you know
sign in blood that you're 100 pure
so what we're trying to do is reach out
to people who have an interest in one
freedom issue one issue because
everybody's got something um or at least
let's say you know 40 million people um
if not 100 men where there's one thing
that they say yes the government needs
to stay out of my life with this
and what we're doing is we're looking at
these um different people and saying
okay
come on into the liberty movement and
let's see what else
would interest you with freedom now some
things are uh obvious and we have found
through doing surveys and that's what
people for liberty is doing we found
through surveys that if you are for
cannabis reform then you're also for
criminal justice reform and that's
pretty
obvious right but there are some less
obvious ones like if you are for school
choice
it turns out that your adjacent issue or
the thing that you're most likely to say
yes i'm for this as well
is getting rid of licensing laws because
so many people who want school choice
they've tried to hire somebody to tutor
or to teach a class to get credit for
whatever and then they find out oh
there's all these licensing laws we
can't send our kid here and especially
with covid when uh parents couldn't send
their kids to the real school so they
try to find hey let's find you know
college students or professors whatever
to teach and it's like no can't do that
so what we're trying to do is bring
people in on one issue and then ex you
know slowly
the only issue i see with something like
that is going back to gay marriage which
you just mentioned it was a libertarian
party that that that spearheaded that as
soon as it became trending the democrats
threw that under their umbrella and said
yeah this is a part of us so if if
you're only going on one case on trying
to reel people in then you're gonna reel
people in but as soon as there's a
popular
movement for that then one of the
parties which however which one that
aligns more with are just going to swipe
that under the rug for them and say yeah
this is what we stand for well two
points and i might not have made this
clear
it first if when i say one issue it's
different for different people like i
said some people it'll be cannabis other
people school choice other people health
care and by the way health care is one
of my top issues so we're not we're not
out there pushing one issue
we're just saying if you have one issue
we don't care what it is come on in and
let's introduce you to some other people
and the second thing is you know what if
the democratic party
um
grabs on to it
and passes laws so now we have marriage
equality fine
uh you know like they
one of the famous things is that the
socialists in you know their 1920
platform or whatever
never elected a socialist and yet every
one of their planks got in if i can get
my planks in i don't care who gets them
in but by the way we're about to get a
coloring uh two things before we wrap up
do you have an opinion on dave smith
well do i
yes is it a good one is it a bad one
what's your perspective on him because
he's he's getting a lot of younger
people to pay attention to him yeah um
it's
uh i mean like everything else some good
some bad
how different are you and him what
differences do you guys have
uh philosophically
not much
okay i mean well actually i i don't want
to say that i mean
no let me take that back
when it comes like health care
no no difference i'm sure although i
haven't heard him speak directly to
health care
education probably not much choice or
not much difference but there are some
there are many things that he has said
that i'm 100 against
so
such as
oh such as
if it's if if you're a man and you want
sex
and
you can't get it by persuasion then you
can give a woman 12 drinks and it's okay
i don't think that's okay
that's what he said
that's what he said that you can give a
woman 12 drinks he said he said if he
gives that's a strategy specifically
right right that's that's interesting
right was that an article yeah was that
an offhand comment an interview how did
he present what you heard and you just
repeated um
so it was reported to me that he said it
um on his podcast and then when people
protested he posted it and put it in
writing and also i disagree you know
yeah let's
let's just say that's one of several
okay okay so let me just ask another
question before we uh do this was
january 6th an insurrection or was it a
protest
it was a total misguided
protest
and and i'm so glad that they found that
first person not guilty
that the guards basically let them in
these people didn't plan a resurrection
they didn't have maps
they were just people who were angry and
upset
and
i
you know if somebody vandalized
something if somebody hurt somebody
absolutely they needed they need to be
brought to justice because you have the
right to life liberty and property but
when the security guard opens the door
for you
you know it should be nothing
trespassing at the most but he didn't
even get uh
that right he he was um found not guilty
of that so fantastic folks i hope you
enjoyed this as much as i did uh my dad
is here if my dad it's his 80th birthday
and i told him i want to get him on the
podcast and he has no clue that we were
going to get him on the podcast but he
apparently showed up i didn't think he
was going to do it because my dad
doesn't like the camera is he do you see
him or no because that door is open
they're grabbing him they're grabbing
them okay so while he's doing that uh i
see jen in there oh you see jen and jen
who is here john oh we got people oh
everyone is here okay come on brooklyn
is in the house
brooklyn kai maybe let him sit right
here
sean we got balloons we got janito look
at all those balloons
you got all those let me see brooklyn
come here baby
this is too many people huh brooklyn
yeah we can change that we can change
that we can change how we can change
that
oh joe we do this every show
apparently
it looks well organized
to
you
happy birthday to
you
happy birthday dear gabriel
happy birthday to you
holy moly
what was that brooklyn
what was that if she starts crying mario
i'm telling you right now come here
question for you after listening today's
podcast
how you feeling huh
pop you want to say something everybody
wants to hear from you know i should
come to thai and mikey come to me
yeah let's hear the mic put it up a
little bit
uh uh so how you feeling man come a
little closer to the mic please thank
you very much for this
surprise i never
yes 80 years 80 crazier
80 years old huh yeah eight years fly
then
this is it
so are you the question after today's
you know are you now a libertarian
because of joe jorgensen are you are you
going to be a libertarian did you pay
attention to what she was saying with
her argument or
did you listen to the podcast
no
okay he's behind on pockets he's still
on francis zangano
so
yeah i know he did i know he did and we
said last night that we're going to get
them on i think that's the first time
yeah brooklyn this the first time you're
on or second time is this the first time
she's on
for second time she came before or no
okay very cool what do you think this is
say something
say baby
[Music]
baby
pop um give us some kind of advice man
adam yesterday said what advice do you
have for us we were having a nice glass
of wine we were having good
conversations just patient be patient be
patient the life you don't know what's
going on
and every single day you're receiving a
box yep there is everything in that box
the day you're follow to end and if you
review
it wasn't yours it was a god that giving
you the
gift and to using it as a
great positive thing
be positive
[Music]
yeah
there is the two thieves walking with
you you can't sue them you can't do
anything they're taking everything from
you
before you know what's happening
you know i'm gonna do it tomorrow for
sure
i'll start it tomorrow for sure there is
no tomorrow for that person if you want
to start right now
right now i gotta go guys
no
this is a
simple way that success
of course yeah let me tell you i said
this last night i said this now my
sister's here pull out if you want to
come a little closer so the audience can
see you as well but i said this
yesterday when we were having dinner
because what year was it when he had his
big big heart attack was it the 93 or 94
94
94 right and i remember for the longest
time you kept your packs of cigarettes
in the kitchen you lost that packs of
cigarettes what'd you do with it i wish
i could find it yet no some
[Music]
we friend they came and smoked they
smoked that back in the last pack of
cigarettes they smoked yeah
by the way mice mikey
alfred unfree gracious
yes
anyways uh but we were saying yesterday
how uh lucky we are i am personally that
god chose you as my dad my life has
changed because of you i am the man i am
because of you every day i thank god for
you i know paulette and i feel the same
way uh you have a very unique way of
leading loving
and the standard you set of a man that
when you said you're going to do
something to do
you and paulette through this two
i love six grandchildren six grandkids
six grandkids man that's pretty intense
yeah listen if i had it my way you would
have 14 more
[Laughter]
we're done with that anyways okay well
listen thank you very much thank you
very much maybe one of adam you know
what we got to do one day says we got to
do podcasts we just sit down with pops
and we do a podcast with them okay
now we're going to do it one day we sit
down maybe we uh have the family we got
your cake here but
[Music]
brooklyn you are not nervous at all with
all these people around you she had to
run this room right she's yeah she's uh
she's very comfortable right now yeah
the girl who was born on our anniversary
june 26th
crazy today we'll never forget okay
brooklyn you okay we finished a podcast
is that okay with you we love you baby
girl daddy love you so much papa thank
you so much thank you thank you thank
you for sticking around everybody dr
george jorgensen thank you for coming
out
taking all the questions to wrap up the
podcast with uh where can people find
you where they can learn more about what
you're doing next if people wanted to
find you is there a website is it
twitter is there somewhere to go find
you
people
the number four
liberty.org
people4liberty.org let's put the link
below put it in the chat box put it in
the comment section put it in the
description put it everywhere uh you
heard it today maybe if you do decide to
run we'll bring you back and we'll ask
some of the same questions and maybe
we'll have different kind of answers who
knows but so maybe we'll do this again
in the future thank you so much for
coming i appreciate you thank you thank
you everybody have a great weekend bye
bye bye bye bye happy birthday pops
thank you
[Applause]
you